[Musique]
le bonsoir à tous c'est parti pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
avec tv 78 bienvenue dans ce journal
tout de suite les titres de ce lundi 4 4
février
le grand débat national arrive à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ir trappe
accueilli une réunion à l'initiative de
la députée lrm nadia est en présence
d'une invitée agnès buzyn est la
ministre de la santé est venu assister
aux échanges et écouter les propositions
des participants
les lycéens de classe de terminale ont
jusqu'au 14 mars pour saisir leurs voeux
sur la plateforme parcours super
pourquoi pas continuer ses études dans
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise entre
universités écoles ou encore quand tu ce
numérique l'offre est riche sur le
territoire nous en parlons avec notre
invité philippe guiguen et puis les
cartons du chesnay versailles en basket
de versailles en rugby et la venue de
jérôme le banner à villepreux c'est à
retenir dans l'actualité sportive du
week-end tour d'horizon à la fin de ce
journal
et puis autres invités de cette édition
la psychanalyste catherine grand jard
coauteur de la femme qui voit de l'autre
côté du miroir elle sera en dédicace
samedi prochain à la librairie le pavé
du canal à montigny le bretonneux
elle se dit oublié par le grand débat
national la banlieue parisienne
aujourd'hui à la rencontre des manuels
macron présent à evry courcouronnes en
essonne le président de la république a
échangé avec 300 personnes élus
franciliens mais aussi des acteurs
associatifs et des citoyens impliqués
dans la politique de la ville dans la
salle des maires des yvelines comme
celle de chanteloup-les-vignes catherine
a renoué vice-présidente également du
conseil départemental le maire de
maurepas aussi grégory à garer sied à
participer à ce rendez vous le grand
débat national qui a donc débuté à saint
quentin en yvelines à l'initiative de la
députée nadia une première réunion était
organisée à trappes est la ministre de
la santé agnès buzyn a aussi fait le
déplacement et d'essai des échanges
animés par les citoyens autour de
plusieurs thématiques le reportage de
nicolas landry et de manon va râteau
c'est l'une des réponses du gouvernement
à la crise des gilet jaune engagé le
grand débat national
la mise en place d'une grande
concertation de terrain a commencé at
ap derrière cette initiative la députée
nadia est ce que j'attends en fait de
ceux de cette journée c'est que la
parole soit vraiment ni la plus libre
possible que personne ne s'auto sont sur
un débat sous forme de petites tables
rondes par thématiques avec à chaque
pôle un rapporteur général pouvoir
d'achat fiscalité les discussions
étaient bien nourris
s'il est ans mettez le doigt sur cette
fiscalité l'exil fiscal qui nous coûte
80 milliards par an il travaille alors
que la france mérite beaucoup mieux les
représentants des associations de
trappes ont également soumis leurs idées
on voudrait que l'état reprenne la
gestion des bailleurs c'est à dire en
profondeur c'est à dire de ce qu'ils
font de l'argent
les participants ne venait pas à tous de
trappes à l'image de cet habitant
militant pour une meilleure fiscalité et
avant de faire une réforme fiscale
commencé par produire des richesses que
l'exemple que j'ai pris vont distribuer
les pommes elle va produire les pommes
certains citoyens en ont profité pour
interpeller la ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn souvent on a un traitement
par exemple pour quatre jours on savoure
what la durée du traitement 160 jours
sur les traitements coup on est en train
de travailler sur la dispensation
médicaux enfin pilule par pilule les
élus locaux étaient également présents
pour ce grand débat il ya des décisions
de fond à prendre dans la solidarité
l'égalité
un certain nombre d'éléments
administratifs qui sont superflus on
peut moderniser la france
elle en est capable et elle en a besoin
deux heures des échanges qui ont permis
aux élus députés et à la ministre de se
rendre compte de la situation sur le
terrain entre tout ce qui est fait au
niveau d'un gouvernement et la façon
dont ça se concrétise dans le quotidien
des gens et bien il ya un énorme écart
c'est peut-être la leçon qu'on peut
tirer c'est que on doit se parler plus
fréquemment en direct tous les citoyens
attendent à présent la fin de ce grand
débat national pour voir sa finalité et
les décisions politiques qui seront
prises et toujours en politique prochain
scrutin en vue celui des européennes le
26 mai prochain et le versaillais
françois-xavier bellamy conduira la
liste les républicains un choix qui ne
séduit pas à droite en raison des
positions anti mariage pour tous et
surtout anti ivg du professeur de
philosophie des cadres du parti comme
les yvelinois valérie pécresse et gérard
larcher ont exprimé leurs réserves la
présidente de la région ancien proche de
simone veil et le président du sénat
étaient présents aux voeux de saint
quentin en yvelines
interrogé par wilfrid richy et patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est une personne que de grande valeur
et pour lequel j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et
d'amitié
mais ses positions sur un certain nombre
de sujets de société ne sont pas les
miennes et je ne veux pas qu'on pense
que les positions sur les sujets de
société de françois-xavier bellamy sont
celles de la droite française
je ne veux pas qu'on que les sujets de
sociétés viennent polluer notre campagne
européenne
nous attendons la suite de la lys donc
clairement je soutiendrai et
accompagnerait cette liste mais il est
vrai que
ce choix là n'était pas mon choix mais
je suis dans une famille politique je
suis aux côtés de la famille politique
et la liste complète du parti les
républicains pour les européennes
devraient être dévoilés dans les
prochains jours c'est un moment clé pour
les jeunes en terminale ils n'ont plus
qu'un mois un peu plus d'un mois pour
choisir ce qu'ils feront
après le bac des voeux à saisir sur
parcours sup un choix souvent cornélien
mais des solutions multiples existe en
tout cas à saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir filet big n bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines de délégués
notamment pardon aux affaires
universitaires le territoire qui dispose
d'une offre d'enseignement supérieur à
la carte vous propose tout de suite de
regarder ce sujet doré lyon et on en
discute juste après vingt mille
étudiants répartis sur cinq campus
yvelinois lu vs qu propose plus de 200
formations diplômantes du dut au
doctorat elle apparaît dans plusieurs
classements internationaux parmi les
plus prestigieux shanghai ou encore
celui du times higher education saint
quentin en yvelines accueille également
sur son territoire de nombreux
établissements pour des formations plus
spécialisés la filière du transport est
représenté avec l'estac à l'école
battini le bretonneux propose des
formations d'ingénieurs en cinq ans
après le bac l en
l'automobile est depuis la rentrée 2010
8 son propre campus à guyancourt samson
jeunes se forment dans le commerce mais
aussi la maintenance auto moto et vélo
pour celles et ceux qui souhaitent opter
pour les métiers de bouche le lycée
d'hôtellerie et de tourisme est
implantée à guyancourt à plaisir l'école
lenôtre permet également de se former
aux métiers de cuisine ou de pâtissier
son spectacle images le premier campus
audiovisuel européen se trouve à saint
quentin en yvelines plus précisément à
elancourt avec plus de 12000 mètres
carrés d'infrastructures 3e reçoit près
de 900 étudiants chaque année
enfin devenir développeur web community
manager ou analystes en cybersécurité en
quelques mois seulement
en 2018 l'agglomération a lancé son
label école du numérique
cet organisme a labellisé propose une
quinzaine de formations
objectif répondre aux besoins des
entreprises saint-quentinoise est avec
moi sur ce plateau philippe le guen
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin en yvelines délégué aux affaires
universitaires or la formation qui fait
la une du dernier numéro de ski mag le
journal de l'agglomération le but c'est
quoi c'est dire à ces jeunes qui
cherchent en ce moment peut-être une
formation sur parcours succès de dire
regardez à saint quentin en yvelines il
y à une offre variée tout à fait comme
l'a démontré votre votre sujet très très
bien très bien fait ce qui est important
de savoir c'est que sur notre territoire
autant notre territoire et dynamique au
point de vue économique nous avons
exactement la même chose au point de vue
de l'enseignement de la formation ainsi
que la formation professionnelle nous
avons à peu près sur le territoire 17
mille étudiants 13500 qui sont au titre
de l'ue vs qu plus tout un tas un nombre
important deux formations adjacentes
aussi bien des écoles d'ingénieurs que
vous avez cités comme l'estaca qui est
renommé un lycée hôtelier l'inauguration
en 2018 du campus de l'automobile et de
la mobilité qui a aujourd'hui 500
personnes en formation qui va monter
jusqu'à 1000 nous avons également lancé
comme s'est précisée l'école du
numérique a vait
que près de 300 personnes qui vont être
formés mais ceci n'est qu'une première
étape que nous sommes pour l'instant
uniquement au niveau haut niveau elle au
niveau lié au niveau licence il ya un
mot tout à l'heure il ya aussi dix sept
mille entreprises sur ce territoire de
50 en une ça veut dire quoi faire ses
études à 50 en imsa peut multiplier les
chances d'être embauché au sein de ces
entreprises vous à vous avez
parfaitement résumé moi qui viens du
monde du monde de l'entreprise on sait
très bien que lorsqu'il y a un bassin
d'emploi s'il y a un bassin de formation
qui est adaptée à cet emploi
automatiquement ça multiplie les chances
de déboucher au niveau des étudiants
vous parliez de l'ue vs q cette
université versailles saint quentin avec
plus de 200 formations qui est
pleinement aussi qui va être pleinement
intégré dans cette grande université
paris saclay sassine locomotive pour le
territoire alors c'est une locomotive
pour le territoire mais il faudra être
très vigilants à ce que l'ue vs qu
tiennent la totalité de sa place au
niveau de paris saclay et ce comme l'a
rappelé notre président lors de la
cérémonie des voeux pas à l'horizon 2025
mais avant vous évoquez aussi cet aspect
mobilité qui est fort sur le territoire
avec l'école d'ingénieurs de l'estaca
est également le touriste en campus des
métiers et des services de l'automobile
à guyancourt
ça c'est aussi essentiel ce côté
mobilité
cette offre de formation mobilité tout à
fait de même que tout va évoluer dans
les entreprises au travers du numérique
nous devons nous adapter en permanence
toutes les formations doivent s'adapter
et ceci en est l'exemple tout à fait
valable les quatre organismes de
formation à son présent sur sur ce
campus de l'automobile un autre secteur
juste avant de regarder un autre sujet
si le secteur de l'audiovisuel ça nous
concerne aussi atv soixante dix huit
avec la présence à elancourt de 3e
l'institut de l'image et du son y est
même un parcours jeu vidéo maintenant
qui est proposée au sein de cette école
tout à fait une école qui est le premier
campus universitaire privé d'europe 1
qui a une par une grande partie des
étudiants sur saint quentin mais
également une autre partie en province
et parmi ces offres aussi le cfi de
montigny le bretonneux ce centre de
formation en alternance se consacre à la
domotique le génie informatique et
l'électronique robotique le site ouvrait
ses portes ce week-end pour
rencontrer ses futurs étudiants marylène
yapi chino et mélanie poker donc on
travaille avec le secteur public les
mairies les conseils généraux on a pas
mal
et aussi le secteur privé les grandes
entreprises à l'école connecté au futur
de l'industrie de montigny le bretonneux
la formation est en apprentissage un
mois et demi en école un mois et demi en
entreprise
le cfi appartient à la chambre des
commerce industrie paris donc
cet organisme qui est d'état donc c'est
dans des écoles publiques et gratuites
ont tout laissé entreprises sont
référencés au niveau des sessions
découvertes industrie donc de ce fait on
a des buts quatre personnes dédiées qui
ne font que ça qui voudraient une
entreprise partir du moment où les gens
sont au côté admis on met en place un
parcours d'accompagnement donc ça va du
cv de la lettre de motivation en allant
jusqu'à l'entretien d'embauché on leur
donne en conclusion tous les outils et
les méthodes nécessaires pour mener au
mieux leur recherche de leur entreprise
d'accueil
le cfi forme des apprentis du bac pro
jusqu'au master et propose des études en
informatique en électronique et en
robotique
l'objectif derrière ce serait d'intégrer
une entreprise en rapport avec la
formation du coup dans la conception
robotique
bon après derrière j'ai le projet aussi
de faire ma propre micro entreprise
d'événementiel aux étudiants de
travailler dans un projet qui est à la
réducation des bras après les avc dans
la filière robotique une cinquantaine
d'étudiants travaillent sur la
programmation sur la conception il
intègre le site en bac + 2 et bac + 3 on
travaille soit sous la robotique ont pas
la robotique c'est un sujet très vaste
donc soit c'est la robotique
industrielle
donc nous parle plutôt en fonds propres
à quoi on parle de la robotique
d'assistance avec un autre établissement
situé sur orly l'école connecté au futur
de l'industrie accueille 800 étudiants
alors fibre digues et non on l'a vu des
formations post bac à saint quentin mais
aussi dans ce sujet ce qu'on a vu s'il
ya des formations pour les plus jeunes
en alternance
avant le bac aussi tout à fait
l'objectif est de couvrir le panel
complet de fonds de formation depuis le
ca paix jusqu'au nez jusqu'au niveau
ingénieur et ce type de formation est
nécessaire notamment dans le numérique
mais également dans d'autres dans
d'autres métiers bien entendu une forme
numérique aussi aux métiers de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration ce lycée
hôtelier qui est l'un parmi l'un des
meilleurs de france qui est parmi l'un
des meilleurs de france qui a un taux
d'emploi la sortie de
des formations quasiment à 100% donc
c'est la preuve que l'excellence paye
sur 50 ans alors un dernier point sur le
campus numérique que vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure ça a été lancée en 2010 est
sous le nom d'école du numérique à
l'époque à saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui treize formations du secteur
qui sont pas forcément toutes références
et sur parcours sup
si une autre possibilité ça c'est le
côté numérique aussi bien bien vendu
dans l'est dans les années à venir dans
les dix ans à venir 80% nous métiers
vont être impactée par l'évolution du
numérique
il est donc très important de s'adapter
dès à présent au numérique et qui
comprend un autre exemple qui est aussi
très très recherchée sur notre sur notre
secteur c'est tout ce qui concerne la
cybersécurité alors treize formations
est ce que l'objectif c'est d'en
proposer de nouvelles tout à fait
l'objectif est d'en proposer de
nouvelles nous en sommes au niveau
licence jusqu'à présent et l'objectif
est de passer jusqu'à jusqu'à une école
d'ingénieurs si l'objectif donc du coup
de continuer de développer cette offre
de formation
tout à fait merci à philippe km est
repassé sur ce plateau il rappelle que
vous êtes conseiller communautaire de
saint quentin en yvelines et délégué aux
affaires universitaires et pour
retrouver toute cette offre de formation
sur le territoire rendez vous sur le
site de l'agglomération qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
l'actualité en bref une affaire qui
s'éclaircit l'ex mari d'isabelle jaubert
tu à cerner la ville a avoué le meurtre
l'homme arrêté vendredi a été déféré
devant le parquet de versailles
il va être mise en examen pour
assassinat et tentative d'assassinât le
24 janvier dernier
cette professeur de sport de 48 en
amoureux à coups de marteau et couteau
ses parents présents au moment des faits
ont été eu a gravement blessé
ils sont au coeur de la polémique les
ailes bdc lanceurs de balles de défense
utilisée pour le maintien de l'ordre
notamment dans les manifestations des
gilet jaune lui a subi un tir de l bd
lors de l'acte iv des gilet jaune à
paris le 8 décembre c'était lent
courtois de 48 ans porte plainte contre
x pour violence volontaire il a été
touché par une balle en caoutchouc à
l'arrière du crâne alors qu'il faisait
demi tour face aux crs selon ses propos
116 enquêtes ont été ouvertes par l'igpn
la police des polices depuis le début du
mouvement
rappelons que le conseil d'état a
confirmé vendredi l'autorisation de l'
usage de ces lbd alors deux
manifestation nouvel invité kim a
rejoint en plateau catherine grand jard
bonsoir un sens alors vous êtes psycho
psychanalyste pardon vous êtes basé à
des nez et spécialiste de l'obésité et
vous avez publié l'an passé aux éditions
eyrolles la femme qui voit de l'autre
côté du miroir co écrit avec la
journaliste daphnée leportois il vous
serait d'ailleurs en dédicace samedi
prochain à la librairie le pavé du canal
à montigny le bretonneux alors ce livre
parle bien sûr de l'obésité mais sous
une forme de roman c'est l'histoire de
lucie une jeune femme de 25 ans qui se
voit comme comme gros sel à 30 kilos en
trop et elle décide pour son
anniversaire de s'offrir une chirurgie
de l'obésité mais rien ne va se passer
comme prévu
bien sûr puisque on va tout de suite
posé les cartes en lui disant mais vous
n'êtes pas que gross
dites moi qui vous aide quelle personne
nous aide quelle est votre histoire est
donc ainsi on va traiter la personne et
pas des kilos puisqu'il est toujours
question d'une personne derrière le fait
d'être mal dans sa peau elle elle
attribue à ses kilos tous ces soucis
est ce si sûr donc nous on va essayer de
voir avec elle c'est une fiction où il
est appuyé sur une vingtaine d'années de
pratique et qui veut montrer à ce grand
public ce qu'il en est des problèmes des
personnes en excès de poids ce qu'il en
est de la chirurgie de l'obésité la
grossophobie de tout ça c'est vraiment
un roman très grand public qui pourtant
donne des informations extrêmement
sérieuse derrière un style léger
justement vous aviez vous êtes l'auteur
de deux essais sur l'obésité pourquoi
prendre le parti cette fois ci de le
faire sous forme de romans pour
atteindre un public qui aime les romans
je vais pas demander au public de parler
mon langage mais en revanche moi je peux
parler le langage de ceux à qui j'ai
envie de m'adresser donc un grand public
je fais de la vulgarisation
je supplie qu'analyste je veux montrer
ce qu'il ya derrière le miroir ce dont
il s'agit en réalité plutôt que de dire
uniquement pour perdre des kilos qui
vous pèse
allez manger mieux et moins et bouger
plus ça c'est tout à fait
stupide étant donné que le problème est
ailleurs
et le problème est pourquoi et comment
on se situe visage et son corps pourquoi
et comment on est bien ou mal dans sa
peau dorée et expliquer aussi dans le
roman tout le processus avant une
chirurgie de l'obésité notamment ce
fameux protocole qu'il faut suivre et
qui prévoit notamment la consultation
d'une dune ou d'un psychologue
l'histoire de lucie finalement c'est
celle de deux femmes et d'hommes que
vous avez pu croiser mais vous savez en
france il ya eu cinq cent mille
interventions chirurgicales de l'obésité
depuis le début depuis une vingtaine
d'années l'année dernière 60 milles
il y à une prévalence supérieurs des
chirurgies à l'augmentation l'obésité ça
pose vraiment un gros problème c'est
quelque chose qui vous inquiète
totalement leur album de l'igas de
septembre dernier 2018 disait qu'il y
avait non seulement trop de chirurgie
mais surtout qu'elle était mal préparé
et mal suivi et c'est cela qui pose
problème il ya 40 % d'échec
donc lorsque quelqu'un va sur son corps
modifier quelque chose un organe en
bonne santé autant que ça serve à
quelque chose sur ce parcours
avant cette chirurgie de l'obésité ce un
parcours qu'on dit pluridisciplinaire
pourquoi il est nécessaire je fais pas
ça parce qu'une personne s'est pas
simplement une assiette
comment il se nourrit c'est pas
simplement une psyché pourquoi et
comment elle fonctionne comme ça c'est
un tout un mode de vie et les raisons
pour lesquelles on peut trouver refuge
dans la nourriture les raisons pour
lesquelles on peut avoir besoin de 100
robes et pour se protéger parce que
parfois c'est aussi une bonne solution
de ne pas être dans les critères du
corps idéal tel que la société le
définit et l'impôt un diktat de la
minceur la perfection et on le vôtre en
aval de réfection vous savez bien ce qui
va se passer dans quelques semaines il
va falloir se préparer pour aller à la
plage comme si ça ne suffisait pas pour
aller à la plage d'avoir un corps et une
plage non il va falloir gommer tout ce
qui peut déborder du bikini et c'est
tout ça qui pose problème parce qu'on
fabrique de l'obésité on fabrique des
complexes physiques et c'est à cause des
complexes physiques que certaines
personnes femmes et
vont penser qu'il est indispensable de
faire des régimes qui fabrique de
l'excès de poids
donc vous voyez tout ce mécanisme est un
reprendre est à comprendre
alors moi si je suis passé à la fiction
à quelque chose qui peut expliquer au
plus grand nombre de personne ce dont il
est question en réalité
et bien c'est parce que je souhaite que
les informations des spécialistes
puissent être donnée à ceux et à celles
qui en ont besoin et c'est ça le l'objet
du passage un roman co écrit avec une
jeune journaliste daphnée leportois
parce que pour passer au roman arrêter
de faire du discours comme des essais
c'est un peu compliqué et pourquoi
l'histoire d'une femme ya plus de femmes
d'aujourd'hui qui veulent recourir à
cette charge de l'obésité il ya plus de
femmes parce qu'elles les hommes vont
recourir plus tard pour des raisons de
santé les femmes plutôt également pour
des raisons d'esthétique mais yaya il ya
les diktats qui pèse différemment sur
les corps selon qui vous êtes un beau
femmes et du coup l'objectif pour vous
c'est de changer changer les regards
peut-être changer la vision de la
société / / bas sur cette thématique de
l'ancien tennis yeux parce que la
grossophobie c'est quand même une peur
de quelque chose qui pourrait nous
arriver aux uns et aux autres et à cause
de cette phobie et bien il y à quelque
chose qui est vécu comme un drame si
vous prenez quelques kilos donc en
changeant le regard du grand public
eh bien peut-être déjà ils vont regarder
les gens - méchamment les personnes qui
sont en excès de poids les enfants qui
sont en excès de poids qui se prennent
des quolibets insupportable à l'école et
qu'il ordonne coin a envie de retrouver
un bonbon parce que le bonbon c'est pas
mauvais mot vert quand on l'écouté c'est
bien que ça fait plaisir
donc tout ça est très important et c'est
comme ça que des gens sont mal dans leur
peau et donc vont après se réfugier dans
quelque chose qui fait pour donner du
plaisir on a compris donc je changer les
regards une dernière question sur sur
les dédicaces alors vous serez en
dédicace lady à la libre et le pavé du
canal
ce samedi à partir de 15h ce si
important pour vous d'aller à la
rencontre des lecteurs de leur billet la
démarche les rencontres individuelles
qu'offrent les dédicaces les salons
parce que je suis aussi au salon du
livre le 17 mars et dans une autre
librairie des yvelines enfin tout ça on
retrouve sur mon blog qui s'est affichée
qui s'affiche pas actuellement mais qui
avait pu s'afficher pendant l'entretien
oui oui voilà un autre manière il suffit
de taper mon nom et retrouve des infos
c'était important les échanges informels
dans les dédicaces dans les salons tout
ça c'est extrêmement important pour
peut-être rassuré pour redonner
confiance à des personnes qui sont en
très grave difficulté avec leur
apparence physique
merci catherine grand joueur je vais
prendre le livre pour le montrer à la
caméra je rappelle que vous êtes là co
auteurs de cet ouvrage la femme qui voit
de l'autre côté du miroir c'est aux
éditions eyrolles et je rappelle que
vous avez des sources très pardon en
dédicace avec votre co auteur daphnée
leportois ce samedi à la librairie le
pavé du canal à montigny le bretonneux
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau le
sport dans les yvelines s'est tout de
suite dans ce journal
[Musique]
et c'est bien sûr michael et demi
d'euros qui s'y colle comme chaque
semaine dont soir bonsoir grégory
comment ce tour d'horizon par du basket
féminin une véritable démonstration ce
dimanche 3 février les filles du chesnay
versailles en blanc et bleu se sont
largement imposés à domicile contre
l'union sportive la glacerie
le score est sans appel 75 à 39 on
appelle cela dans le jargon un score
fleuve cette 13e victoire de la saison
en nationale 3 était acquise dès les
premières minutes de la rencontre avec 1
13 à 1 après quatre minutes de jeu
seulement
on écoute les réactions passé les
matches qui sont difficiles à jouer
parce que c'est une équipe qui est bas
tableau clairement qui joue qui joue son
maintien
donc elles ont elles ont rien à perdre
elles ont avec les crocs donc faut faire
attention au palais faut pas les prendre
de haut où tout de suite rentré dans le
match est concentré on a réussi à le
faire donc c'est bien je pense qu'on
était sérieux on était concentré
et à la fin les cartes qu'on a fait
c'est je pense qu'on le mérite
cette victoire permet aux féminines du
chesnay versailles de conserver la
première place du championnat le fcv 70
villes comptent trois points d'avancé
sur le duo gravenchonnais angers après
14 journées des résultats qui permettent
d'envisager montée en fin de saison du
rugby à présent michael est là encore un
score fleuve
alors je sais que vous aimez quand une
équipe maîtrise parfaitement son sujet
jusqu'au coup de sifflet final
les rugbymans de versailles ont réussi
un vrai festival offensif dans le
championnat honneur les versailles et se
sont imposés vous le voyez à l'écran ce
n'est pas une erreur 88 à 0 à domicile
face à l'entente gonesse goussainville à
14 essais inscrits la douzième victoire
en douze journées pour les joueurs de la
cité royale qui sont toujours en tête du
championnat et qui ne sont plus qu'à
quelques points de la montée en fédérale
3 et on termine ce tour d'horizon par
une visite de marque d'une visite aussi
de de poids à villepreux lui aussi aime
donner des roustes l'ancien kick boxeur
professionnel français est aujourd'hui
acteur jérôme le banner est venu donner
pour la première fois un stage de pieds
poings à une quarantaine d'élèves au
gymnase alain mimoun il est resté au
total trois heures sur place pour leur
apprendre des techniques de combat ce
sportif d'un mètre quatre-vingt-dix pour
cent vingt kilos de muscles surnommé the
bulldog of normandie était au micro de
notre journaliste d'un mètre soixante
marylène iapichino comme sont habitués à
une certaine technique qui se rapproche
plus à lui tu te rappelles avec du
karaté de la self défense
moi je sais plus ce côté on va dire que
ça prend une mitraillette et moi je veux
avoir le bazooka
bon c'est bien d'avoir de désarmement il
faut après que ce germe dans le dans la
tête du professeur de répéter répéter en
fait celui où c'est un peu notre sport
dans toutes les disciplines
il faut répéter répéter répéter et
remises et répété voir dans un instant
nous recevrons dans ce set 8 sport de tv
60,18 liquide de taï jitsu de villepreux
qui a invité jérôme le banner
merci michael stutes sport c'est bien
sûr juste après ce journal le journal
qui touche d'ailleurs à sa faim
l'édition est à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]